the things we uncovered were appalling
appalling behaviors I thought these were
things you know decades past in the past
to still find them now you know in the
21st century 2020 to 23 as we have it is
truly shocking and we don't want to
offend our viewers but give us some idea
of what some of the most shocking
instances you found certainly some of
the ones we found so uh yeah a senior
officer using a racist term to refer to
a black colleague and just laugh net off
as as banter two male firefighters
they're joking if you can joke about
these things about raping a female
firefighter then acting that out
homophobic graffiti on someone's Locker
you know truly appalling that's why our
recommendations are so important now